rich this is what happens when i when i
host the show for you
we go down the rabbit hole with howard
beck talking about which
nba journalists would win on survivor
uh we were thinking with you on now
which of your your former colleagues
from sportscenter over the years you
think would live off the land
the best on one of those types of shows
howard beck was so confused for the
first five minutes he didn't know what
was going on
this is a good one who would live off
the land
the best oh man
um who's going fishing like is craig
kilbourne like
using the no i don't know how anglers
there were
right does trey wingo know how to skin a
squirrel to eat it to survive
i don't know kenny kenny mayne is the
one most likely to
have a conversation with a volleyball um
i'm trying i'm trying to figure out
which way to attack this
um attacking so your life depends upon
it rich
i don't know who would be who would live
off the land like robin roberts is the
most likely to
you want to you want an alliance with
robin roberts i think he's trustworthy
he is
she's going to be the only trustworthy
yes she's the only one i form an
alliance
you know what i i i he's he's a little
you know soft
but sharp shap would probably know how
to start a fire you probably
know the history of fire true yeah you
probably know about
the history of wood and chopping wood to
make fire and who was the first person
to do it
so i mean i think he would probably know
which how to survive um
fascinating question ben like i said we
go down the rabbit hole when you're not
around
and this is uh this is the kind of stuff
we we put in the old google machine here
i i don't know what i i don't know if it
means uh
anything for what it's worth we go down
a lot of rabbit holes as well when i'm
there too
you know i mean there's a lot of rabbit
holes i think it's a joke i was going
to recall that any any any survivalists
well obviously people connected rich we
would follow charlie steiner the freedom
right well i mean yeah when everything
went haywire with y2k
charlie was there with a lantern um
so that did happen but that's a good one
i i don't know if any of us would
survive
[Laughter]
rich i've been going down the rabbit
hole watching uh archery highlights
and i've really been enjoying myself uh
i'm not having as much fun though
as you're having doing the archery
highlights
no one's having as much fun as rich did
you did you know going
into this that archery would be
something that you would have a
calling for and a connection to no not
at all i just didn't know
i haven't done a lot of these ever
today there was uh team cycling that i
had to look at the highlight
five six different times to understand
it you know
um and uh
we're having a lot of fun just putting
stuff together you know
um we're the crew is amazing everybody's
having fun having a blast and
and then there's stuff that doesn't make
air
that that would have been great like
today
there was an upset in um uh
women's doubles bag mitten big upset
china lost the gold medal and um
to indonesia but initially we got
some bad information that we thought
uh it was thailand that had beaten china
so i had the line all lined up haven't
not even seen the highlight that match
point
the line would be what's the capital of
thailand and the answer was shuttlecock
[Laughter]
and we were all so profoundly
disappointed to find out that that line
would never make air because it was
indonesia
uh as we know um their their capital is
not bangkok
but um you know i had to explain that
joke to some people who weren't you know
seven years old and had that happen to
them
usually i don't like when broadcasters
have already workshop ideas for the big
moment but that one you get a pass on
that that one sounds like it
it should have come to the left right
and like where there was like a back and
forth
because um you know we we decided to
create a segment
called rich's shuttlecock minute so i
could say the word with impunity
and um basically just spotlight a lesser
known sport
every single time with that and
yesterday
was the triple jump and um
subsequent to us choosing the triple
jump for the shuttlecock minute
somebody went ahead um one of the women
who were doing the triple jump
set an olympic record in her first jump
and then a world record in her second
jump
and there was a little concern you know
that we were giving it short trip
because we made it part of our shuttle
talk minute especially since my lead in
was talking about how the triple jump
goes all the way back to the ancient
games
when the greeks and the romans were
probably drunk and figured let's
top dip in a jump and call it a sport
with my lead in line
this is the stuff i'm so proud of you
have no idea like
ben i'm i'm proud of my children i'm
proud of this show i'm proud of our team
that we have there in that studio
but this sort of stuff really just
lights my lamp like i'm so proud of
myself to come up with these lines
and we kind of like went back and forth
do we make it a different sport
for our minute and i'm like i kind of
like the lead in so much i got to stick
with it we got we'll we'll just make it
work
i don't know if it's true that it was
drunk roman came up with the idea
rich eisen joins the rich eisen show you
catch him of course
non-stop on tokyo gold tj and i were
talking like it feels like you're just
always on doing highlights
that's the way then that's the way you
know the old sports centers used to be
and um back in the
98 world series when i was doing
espn radio broadcast hosting the
coverage of the world series and we were
in san diego that was the
yankees um win over the padres when they
went 125 and 50
by the way um and so um it was my job to
interview
somebody who was there at the game
in the middle of the fifth inning they
would have less of a commercial break
and give time for me to interview
somebody for 90 seconds to two minutes
it was my job to find somebody
in the stands who was worthy of that
interview
like one time it was for game one it was
billy crystal and game three it was
maguire who was
in the stadium because he had just set
the home run record earlier that year
and game four which turned out to be the
final game i saw charlie sheen the actor
charlie sheen
and um i saw him in the stands and i
went up to him
and i said hey where are you going to be
in the fifth inning and he told me he
was going to be in the owner's
suite in the fifth inning to meet him
there for that
interview and i met him there in the
fourth inning and i watched an entire
inning of that world series with charlie
sheen at one point he says to me
you know rich a couple years ago
you know i wasn't doing so well you know
um staying up all night and
kind of you know doing a lot of things i
don't know if you're aware of that i'm
like yeah i'm
aware of that charlie and he's like so i
would watch you
at 10 o'clock at night and then watch
you
at 11 o'clock all the way through
to about four in the morning and right
around two in the morning i would know
what you're going to say before you
sleep
[Laughter]
so i it's one of these repeats i'm back
in the i'm back in the the rear type
thing
so kind of cool i'm back in the wayback
machine here
no and a great fun hollywood fact too
you are forever connected to charlie
sheen's infamous hollywood all-night
benders i had no idea that you were part
of that
i i was part of the sports center tiger
blood before i even knew it i knew
i had no idea so incredible moment
um i don't know if everybody watching or
listening got a chance to see it but
between the high jumpers
who shared a gold medal that doesn't
happen i love it
it was incredible wasn't it yeah i i
i love that sort of stuff i can't get
enough of it and you know then you learn
the back story
that these two guys one from qatar
the other from italy um compete each
other
in in events all over the world
they knew each other wasn't the first
time they met each other they were
friends
and you know they looked at each other
and they they both had jumped 2.37
meters
and then they moved the bar up to 2.39
meters
both of them missed it the tie break
which i did not know in high jump
was how many misses you had earlier
or both of them had made every jump
until missing
the same jump and that's when they went
up to him and said hey
you know we could have a jump off or
you know that's when the the the qatari
said how about
can we just get each get a gold they're
like yeah that's possible and they just
said that's it
and i know others see that and
just like in this world there are
detractors about everything
but i just thought the sportsmanship was
amazing and
um today they they had the medal
ceremony both guys on the top podium and
they put each other's gold medals around
the other guy's neck
wow so the italian put the metal around
the katari's neck and vice versa and i
just
can't get enough of stuff like that it's
awesome
it's exactly why we love the olympics it
should be celebrated more it has been
celebrated throughout these olympics
those moments of just pure
human connection humanity compassion
sportsmanship
and then on the flip side you see for
the men uh in tennis
you see yokovich just like destroy his
racket throw his giant temper tantrum
doesn't get the gold medal what would
you make of the the
implosion he had out there on the court
you know what
it's i i don't know what to make of any
of it but
in the same way that you know so many
people are criticizing biles i'm i'm
just going to take a pass
on this one i can't imagine what it's
like to be in that olympic village in
the middle of this pandemic and the
pressures that are on you for
for your country and he was playing
doubles and singles non-stop
and i know he said something that a
burden thought he was referring to biles
and it sure sounded like it
so if you see his actions certainly
belie
um somebody who can handle the pressure
you know
i i just don't know what it was but you
know like i said i
i prefer to talk about like the great
stuff
like this the the runner from the
netherlands
uh and um
she i don't know if you saw today she's
running a
1500 meter heat and a kenyan runner in
front of her
falls and she trips over her and she
falls
and she gets up and she starts running
and she catches up to the pack and then
she's right next to the leaders and she
blows past them
and she won the heat anyway somebody
falls in front of her she trips and
falls like the ultimate
when you have something happen to you
get up and dust yourself
off and keep going um which
you know i i i couldn't believe that and
then 12 hours later
she's running the actual race for the 5
000
meter the 5k 3.1 miles
and she wins that she blows
past the canyon in that race who and
and and they had to widen out to show
both runners still in the screen that's
how far in front she was
of everyone like the it looked like you
know
a secretariat winning the race you know
like where there was nobody else
in in the framing and that's on the same
day and that's the thing you also have
to remember a lot about these swimmers
that they're running therefore they're
swimming heats and then they
swim a race and it's just non-stop it is
so grueling
but to see a feat like that uh today
it's one
it's my favorite performance of the
olympics in the first 10 days
no it's truly remarkable what she's
doing like you said not only the moment
of her of falling down but just the fact
that 12 hours later she's running the 5k
and then i think she's doing 10 000
meters or something as well i read she's
incredible
they look so they look so um and again
you know speaking as a runner ben
you know they look effortless
like the top parts of their body from
the waist up
don't move it's just their legs like
like the road runner
you know it's i i don't know how they
physically do it
you know uh truly amazing i love
watching this stuff and then i love the
field events you know
the discus the shot put the javelin
um i i love it i love that stuff they
had to stop the discus tonight because
it was
raining but the track events they were
they ran in the rain
like they kept running in the rain and
um the the the shots of the slow motion
rain falling around these runners was
amazing it was just
pretty remarkable so interesting rich to
to hear you speak so passionately about
this
experience because you're somebody who's
covered sports at the highest level for
a long time you casually mention
being at a world series in 98 or working
with the nfl
but it feels like this experience from
the outside looking in has almost like
reconnected you with sports or given you
a deeper
uh greater appreciation just for what it
takes to be a professional athlete how
do you think your relationship with
sports in general
has changed from being a part of this
tokyo gold thing i don't know it's been
pretty neat man it's been pretty neat
but
the whole thing just you know speaking
personally professionally
you know being back in the state of
connecticut doing a highlight show it's
just like i
you know i'm back in a time machine you
know i'm back in a time machine it's a
highlight program and i love the fact
that it proves what i think all of us
believe
um that there is still a market
in this day and age where you see
something in the palm of your hand on
your phone
as it's happening and you also get
reactions
and opinions about something that just
happened in real time on your phones and
your hands
that there still is the need to settle
down
and watch just a recounting through a
well-produced and executed highlight
tv show that will always still
work and i'm i'm thrilled to be
at the tip of that olympic spear for for
us
you know on peacock you know and i say
us because you know we're
talking on peacock right now and that
streamers happening while there
are so many different ways of consuming
things on your on your phone
um the whole thing has been just uh
amazing but i do look forward to getting
back with you guys
well as you've now immersed yourself in
the world of
the 100 meters and the javelin and
long distance running and the shot put
are you keeping tabs on the fact
of like should the knicks commit long
term to evan fournier
like are you thinking about what the
cults are gonna do now that carson wentz
broke his foot or are you just
entrenched with archery well um
i can still you know walk and chew gum
at the same time
and also ignore the knicks um
so i can do all of that at once
now ben are you at any way shape or form
hoping
that this is the year where
um no register rich i mean no
no rich they're going to be terrible
this year they're going to miss the
playoffs
we're not focused on free agency 2021
it's all about zion
rich we're putting it out there now
we're gonna be early on it
so we're really playing for 2024 here
i'm a futurist i'm kanye west i'm living
here
at the rich eisen studios i know you are
i live in connecticut and i greatly
appreciate that by the way no i don't
have any real expectations for this team
i just don't want to see them commit
long term and give somebody a bunch of
money who might not deserve it and
that's classic knicks and that's what
this today's the new july 1st today's
august 1st in the new nba calendar
we're going to see some crazy contracts
and and movements a little bit later
today
anything exciting you were hopeful i
think the nick should just stay the
course keep building what they were
doing and then you never know
you're right about zion i know he said
that mecca comment
um and um we'll see if he actually does
that but it is though
the once of it all is um fascinating you
know on
on friday show when ryan leaf was
sitting in there you know we were having
a conversation
first blush about if went to seriously
hurt what happened
and my first thought was false and foles
had a press conference today where he
basically basically you know
like held up a sign or or or
or or a boom box outside of the colts
window
you know um like say anything and
and say take me like i'm here i'm i'm
buried on this depth
chart i we you know the rookie already
has the veteran to help him which is why
he meant he mentioned that dalton is the
leader this team needs like
basically he said everything like
dalton's here guys
i love rike i don't want to go anywhere
where i don't know the offense already
you know it just again another pop
culture reference it was like creamer
why don't you tell me the name of the
trade you'd like to hear you know like
it's
it's it's it's there it makes
sense the ridiculous time frame of five
to 12 weeks
shows you that you know you're gonna
what you're gonna go into the season
with these unseasoned people who are on
the roster
for four or five weeks when you've got
you know a team in the division like the
titans who are
set to go with julio jones you're gonna
you're gonna fall behind
fast so getting someone like foals
is the no-brainer of no-brainers
that as long as dalton stays healthy
and doesn't get hurt to the point where
the bears are like well now we need
bowls there
and i'm thinking the bears might go
through training camp to see if
just in case that happens because you
know
maggie came on our show right after the
draft and
flat out said he wants to replicate what
he was
front and center on the chief staff for
which was to have
an off you know a a sabbatical year
or a freshman sit down year for fields
like they had for
mahomes i i think they're going to play
their cards close to the vest even
though it makes
sense to do it now that may be like a
mid-august
okay dalton's healthy we can go in the
season with that
we can get rid of foals type thing and
you know david dunn foles's agent is
probably
pounding on the bears front office right
now to get this done it makes too much
sense
it's just crazy how he'll forever be
connected to carson wentz and we'll see
that connection
quit continuing it's insane i know
the one other thing that i was thinking
about and i'm wondering i don't know if
you guys can tell me because i have not
seen this anywhere
is maybe the colts call down to
a high school in alabama and see if
philip rivers
is like eager or
any way shape or form wants to give it
one last swing i have not seen that
anywhere rich you're the first person
that i've heard mention that
you know what i mean like i i i know he
wants to coach and i know he's with his
children
and i know he's probably tapped out
mentally thinking that this thing's over
but don't you think the cults it would
behoove them to just ring them up
and say you know us we know you you know
everything you know what do you think
just one more year the high school will
still be there i know you've made your
commitment and philip sounds like
you know and is one of those guys be
like no i've already told the kids i'm
coming
you know i i don't know but i'm
wondering if the colts have already made
that phone call first
i've been the only one saying this what
if jacob easton is really good
i know i mean why not what if all these
guys are really good i heard too it
would look good in practice today
you know it's august guys why not
everybody looks good in august trey
lance's first three red zone passes all
touchdowns oh boy here we go
oh boy oh boy jimmy's getting upset
jimmy's looking for real estate in
indianapolis
maybe so enjoy the rest of the archery
we appreciate
you so much checking in on your own show
thanks so much rich
all right richard for chising checking
in you guys having fun downstairs you
need anything
i'm upstairs if you need me it's kind of
what it feels like a little bit no
partying i think yeah we're a little
young to be going out we're partying at
the parents house
i'm right upstairs checks in you guys
need anything i'm here
but you guys have fun
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here